the next award goes not to an actress
but to a director the gentleman who will
present it are no stranger to ask her
either
between them they've won three as actors
to Jack Lemmon and Walter Matthau
just don't screw it up hey
now there are all kinds of directors
there are Spectator directors dictator
directors directors that are kind and
tolerant their understanding
there are also directors that are mean
and petty and contemptible some
directors are short and some are tall
are old and some are young our American
directors French Czechoslovakian and
English directors etc there are
directors who know everything about
human behavior and nothing about the
camera
there are directors who know camera
angles camera lenses camera sprockets
and depth of focus but who are totally
ignorant of the human condition
we have all of these directors with us
tonight
also also we have directors who work
well with the camera and with the actors
and one of them is going to win the
Academy Award the nominees for best
achievement in directing are Louie mouth
for Atlantic City
you Hudson for Chariots of Fire
Marc Riedel for on golden time
even Spielberg
and warren beatty for what
the winner is Warren Beatty
thank you Miss Keeton I know that that
public expressions like this can be
embarrassing sometimes and that my
chances of speaking with you privately
later are at the moment excellent I do
want to tell you that you make every
director that you work with look good
and I think that what they're trying to
tell me here tonight thank God is that
I'm no exception mr. Nicholson I know
that you're enjoying my being up here
almost as much as I am in being here I
know I do one thing well I get good
people Elaine May Peter feeble man
Jeremy pick Sir Robert Towne Simon Ralph
Zelda Baron Richie Simmons Ione Steve
Sondheim Dave Grusin David McLeod so
many many more among whom are the people
that you've nominated here tonight and
happily save me from having to remember
to name 14 more names
I do want a name mr. Barry Diller who
runs paramount mr. Dixon Burt has been
very kind to me mr. Frank Mancuso and
mr. charles bluhdorn who runs a Gulf and
Western and God knows what else
and I want to say to you gentlemen that
no matter how much we might have liked
to strangle each other from time to time
I think that your decision taken in the
great capitalistic Tower of Gulf and
Western to finance a
three-and-a-half-hour romance which
attempts to reveal for the first time
just something of the beginnings of
American socialism and American
communism reflects credit not only upon
you I think it reflects credit upon
Hollywood and the movie business
wherever that is and I think that it
reflects more particular credit on the
freedom of expression that we have in
our American society and the lack of
censorship that we have from the
government or the people who put up the
money
you